[Musique]
les français sont les mauvais élèves de
la vaccination selon le dernier sondage
au doxa il est serait plus de 58% ne pas
vouloir du vaccin
vous m'aviez invité le 16 novembre le 19
novembre je crois et je vous avait
expliqué à l'époque que le vrai sujet de
la vaccination
c'était la confiance et c'était la
logistique nous n'avons ni la confiance
ni logistique
un mois et demi plus tard quel pays
d'autres critères comme l'âge et le sexe
sont à prendre en compte
les plus âgés sont plus enclins à se
faire vacciner et les femmes
le serait moins que les hommes la
sensibilité politique n'est pas non plus
à négliger
plus de la moitié des électeurs
d'emmanuel macron sont prêts à se faire
vacciner quand ceux de jean luc
mélenchon et marine le pen sont
largement plus réticents accélérer le
tempo de la vaccination tout en évitant
les fausses notes
c'est la partition que doit jouer le
gouvernement et son ministre de la santé
olivier vers en devient très dur vis
vous aviez à dover actionnaires je
venais de me faire refuser cet
après-midi le ministre est en
déplacement dans cet hôpital parisien
nous n'avons pas le temps de convaincre
les 1 % de gens complotistes nous avons
par contre le mois de janvier pour
convaincre les 30% des indécis et je le
dis au maire
quand votre maire de la commune se fait
vacciner il a encore l'aura de ses
administrés j'avais suggéré ce matin
pour rigoler mais apparemment c'est ça
peut être repris
que mettez ça dans votre salle d'attenté
mettez une photo de vous dans votre
salle d'attenté en train de vous faire
vacciner est marquée en dessous je les
fais pourquoi pas vous six mois en tant
que médecin je vais le faire moi je vais
le faire cette semaine les français ont
aujourd'hui un certain nombre de doutes
vous le savez pas c'est la vaccination
et face à cela ils ont un gouvernement
qui vous l'avez dit fait l'éloge de la
lenteur à certains moments et depuis
hier soir maintenant hyper accélère
puisque olivier ferrand réunir
l'ensemble des directeurs des ars et des
directeurs de centres hospitaliers en
avisant fin du moins il nous faut un
million de personnes vaccinées
nous avons vous le savez décidé
d'accélérer dans notre stratégie
vaccinale en permettant la vaccination
sans délai de ces soignants qu'il soit
hospitalier ou
exerce en secteur libéral il y à une
sorte de pesanteur d'état que l'on voit
il y à une sorte de chez pas de
bureaucratie de technocratie ce qui est
normal en temps de paix on va dire voilà
quand c'est normalement parce qu on fait
attention à tout devient un danger au
moment d'une crise sanitaire comme celle
là notre but majeur c'est diminuer les
décès de diminuer les hospitalisations
vite on vaccine et plus vite mais nous
les décès à condition à condition de
vacciner les bons parce que neuf
personnes qui décident qui décèdent
pardon sur dix en riant ce cd jantes
plus de 65 ans neuf sur dix et un tiers
sont en ehpad
ce bruit qui court à bruxelles c'est que
la france a joué
sanofi au maximum a contraint d'ailleurs
l'europe probablement c'est ce que dit
la presse allemande a privilégié sanofi
contre les autres vaccins dont le fait
que à la fois on est on essaie de forme
de réticence des visas qui ne sera pas
opérable avant la fin de l'année autre
fiasco industriels français des chevaux
devraient saisir cette démonstration de
coiffure n'est autre que celle de
marlène schiappa da ministre délégué
chargé de la citoyenneté qui a posté
cette vidéo sur son compte instagram
officielle avec un commentaire merci
adriano et vincent delahaye nes brasil
pour ce lissage qui répare les cheveux
depuis supprimé la vidéo est passé son
compte en privé donc vous ne pouvez pas
aller voir mais nous si son compte
instagram compte 583 publication elle
poste des photos intimes avec son
conjoint entre deux photos politique
un cliché de la manucure de sa fille un
déguisement d'halloween ou encore
dernières photos en date un tiramisu
avec un petit clin d'oeil qu'on n'a pas
compris a corsica linea une société de
transport privé